yes you read the title correctly i
believe that the next redesigned macbook
air
is gonna have white bezels just like we
got with the new 24-inch imac
and i know you probably think i'm crazy
but i've been collecting a bunch of
little hints that point to an
upcoming macbook with white bezels and
it's finally starting to make sense
so in this video i'm gonna go through
each and every one of those details
based on common sense as well as what
apple has done in the past
to show you why this makes so much sense
for apple to do
right now and then i'm gonna go through
some leaks and rumors
that point to when we should be seeing
this macbook getting released
so let's get right into it first off i
want to discuss what apple has already
done with the new 24-inch imac since
that plays a massive role
in this macbook air theory a ton of
people have been complaining about the
white bezels
and it's probably because it's just so
random
it came out of nowhere and basically
shocked the world
but wait apple actually does have
justification
for this switch and it's actually quite
genius
the number one reason why the new imac
has white bezels
is because it's part of the redesign and
this redesign
is a hundred percent based on apple's
transition to apple silicon
if there was no transition there would
be no
redesign and apple actually said that
themselves
the second reason is because apple wants
their users
and future potential users to instantly
recognize
that this new imac has apple silicon
there is absolutely no way
that anyone could mistake one of these
new apple silicon imacs with one of the
old intel based imacs
it's incredibly thin it's got new colors
it's got white bezels
it's got a chin with no logo it's
blatantly obvious to everyone
that this is a totally new imac now the
third reason or justification
for the white bezels is that apple is
going retro
they're going back to their roots during
the spring-loaded event
they started off with the classic
hellotext from the original mac
they even used screenshots from that
colorful hello text
as the wallpapers for the imacs
themselves
and in their new imac ads they actually
brought back
a redesigned version of the rainbow
apple logo
so apple is obviously going retro and in
terms of the imac itself
apple is obviously doing a sequel to
their iconic imac g3s
from way back in the day with white
bezels and
a bunch of colors and all of this is
being done to make the apple silicon
transition
a really really big deal because it is
and the best way to make it a big deal
is to totally change
everything about the imac and make it as
obvious as possible
that these new macs are nothing like the
old max
and if you think about it it might seem
really weird that apple is giving
the same exact m1 chip to a bunch of
different products
including the ipad pro but what they're
actually doing
is pure genius apple wants that
m1 chip to essentially go viral
because the m1 chip is the symbol of the
apple silicon transition
so if the m1 chip goes viral then the
apple silicon transition goes viral
and the new drastically changed designs
will push
the importance of the transition and
this is finally where the macbook air
redesign
with white bezels comes in a big point
that i want to make is that when apple
changes things up in terms of the design
other products usually follow for
example the 2018 ipad pro got a
redesigned with flat sides
and then the pro display xdr followed
and then the ipad
air followed and then the iphone
followed
and now the imac is following that same
design language
so if the 24 inch imac ends up being the
only mac
or modern apple device with white bezels
that would be extremely weird and random
for apple to do
it's much more likely the apple will
bring these white bezels and various
color options
down to the macbook air which is
essentially the portable
version of the 24 inch imac since both
machines are targeted toward
the younger and more average consumer
market and if you think that that would
be weird for apple to do
check this out because it'll blow your
mind here's an image of the original
imac g3 colors
and this is actually the ibook g3
which was apple's laptop based on that
imac
with the same colors and all and guess
what
they've got white bezels and color
matched accessories
just like apple has on the new 24-inch
imac as well
and take a look at this ad for a newer
white macbook
the totally white macbook for everyone
yes
it's meant for the entry-level market so
if apple is going
full on retro with this imac to
symbolize the transition
then why stop at just the imac and if
you think that i'm alone in thinking
this way
i'm actually not parker over at 95 mac
wrote an
article saying that it's time for the
macbook air to get its ibook moment
and looking at this image it totally
makes sense the concepts he created are
basically
exactly what i can imagine the
redesigned new macbook to look like
white bezels with a white keyboard as
well as a bunch of different color
options
just like we have on the imac and from
taking a look at the comments
there are people who actually like the
idea of a macbook
with white bezels and here's another
very telling hint
from apple that basically puts the nail
in the coffin for the first time ever
apple has released a totally white magic
keyboard case for the ipad pro
which nobody was expecting and this is
obviously hinting
at white macbooks coming in the future
so if apple really wants their new
redesigned macbook air with apple
silicon to look different
the absolute best way to do that is to
add new colors
and make the bezels and the keyboard
white just like on the 24 inch imac
everyone will instantly be able to tell
that you have a brand new
apple silicon macbook air and that is
apple's ultimate goal
even if some people absolutely hate the
design this will just end up making more
controversy
which will result in free marketing for
apple and if you think about it
almost every laptop on the market right
now has black
bezels so if apple gave the macbook air
white bezels
it would be totally unique and it would
push the apple silicon transition
like nothing else would which is apple's
number one goal
and once again it would be extremely
weird for apple to randomly go retro
with white bezels on just the imac and
stop
there and if any other product was going
to follow in its footsteps
it would 100 percent be the entry-level
macbook air redesign
and going even deeper if they're going
to totally redesign the macbook air and
reinvented
why not just give it the original
macbook name
to kickstart a whole new generation of
macbooks
ever since the 12-inch macbook was
discontinued we've been left with the
perfect and original macbook name
which isn't being used and i don't think
the apple will introduce
a small 12-inch laptop ever again just
based on the fact that the iphone 12
mini
is not selling well at all so people
aren't looking for small displays
anymore
so let's just say that apple calls it
the macbook gives it the white bezels
the fun colors the new m2 chip and
bam you've got a killer laptop for a
great price
and it looks like nothing else on the
market now with all that said
i want to finish up with some leaks and
rumors that point to the potential
release date of this macbook
back in january mark german from
bloomberg reported that apple could
launch a new thinner and lighter
redesigned high-end macbook air with mac
safe
in the second half of 2021 he said that
apple is planning on keeping the display
size the same
but shrinking the bezels to make the
overall design smaller and thinner
which goes to show that the 12 inch
macbook is probably gone for good
now ming chi kuo another reliable apple
analyst
believes that apple is more likely to
release this macbook air
sometime in 2022 with a new design
an apple silicon chip and a new mini led
display
and digitimes another publication agreed
with this
saying that the redesigned macbook pros
would be getting mini led
first in 2021 and then that mini led
would trickle down to the macbook air in
2022
and this makes total sense to me since
they would want to give that new midi
led display
to the pro level macbooks first and on
top of that
i believe that the next generation m2
chip isn't going to be ready until
next year since i think it's gonna come
with the same
four plus four core layouts as the m1
currently has
but it's gonna rely on the new rv9
architectural
improvements and a smaller three
nanometer or four nanometer chip
architecture from tsmc to give it more
performance and battery life
and as far as the pricing i think that
it's going to start at around
twelve hundred dollars since that's what
they did in the past with the redesigned
2018 macbook air and then they'll leave
the m1 macbook air with the old design
for 999 for at least
another full year as a budget option so
there you guys have it
those are my thoughts on why the new
macbook air is gonna have
white bezels and if you totally disagree
with me
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed this video go
ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video